alors écoutez je pars quand même du
principe puisque vous avez chanté devant
les caméras de télévision et à la
satisfaction générale je veux dire à la
fois la satisfaction du public deux
jours là qui a beaucoup aimé la
satisfaction de quelques artistes
malveillants qui ont dû robin suis là
ils nous menacent pas
je me suis dis qu'il ya quelque chose
que vous n'aviez pas fait il a fallu
bien chercher pour le trouver vous
n'avez encore jamais joué la comédie ou
en dehors de votre bureau et les
conseille d'être de l'ostracisme qui est
donc un peu tous les jours la même chose
oui oui tandis que la la a je vous ai
concocté un sujet sur mesure on a écrit
pour bernard tapie est devant vous il va
faire des débuts de comédien qui ne
seront peut-être pas sans lendemain
voilà alors le thème est d'une grande
simplicité encore qu'un petit peu
arbitraire vous le concède vous arrivez
au paradis or en attendez je ne sais
même pas si vous êtes morts ou vivants
vous arriver au paradis et vous essayez
de faire des affaires avec saint pierre
ici du mal alors nom prénom et
profession je m'appelle stati bernard et
je suis dans les affaires ben ali les
affaires les affaires simples vacth même
un
spécialité c'est le sauvetage sont tous
je souffre sans arrêt je rachète je
remet d'aplomb je souhaite finalement
j'ai sauvé pas mal de gens
va donc faire un tour
je m'occupais de monsieur
personnellement son cas m'intéresse oui
ben juin-juillet allait marcher un peu
c'est ça va marcher et saint pierre
il est très mal
vous savez que moi aussi j'ai beaucoup
racheter et beaucoup sauver c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on m'appelle le
messie dites moi ça ne vous dérange pas
si on discute un petit peu amènes ont de
si mais non mais si c'est une réponse de
l'or noir
mais non mais si je ne dis pas mais non
mais si je dis mais non mais si mais si
c'est votre nom non j'aurais dit messi
messi sinon veulent pas écouter vous
allez m'appeler jésus parce qu'autrement
on va jamais s'en sortir oui d'accord et
vous acheter quoi alors moi je rachète
des pêcheurs envoyer uniquement des
pêcheurs actuellement vous procédé pour
racheter les pêcheurs alors pour acheter
les pêcheurs j'examine leurs actions
voyez je mets d'un côté les bonnes
actions de l'autre côté les mauvaises
actions et que je regarde si c'est si ça
vaut la peine de racheter ou non et ça
dépend de quel côté penche le fléau de
la balance au la balance sous ou 30 et à
picsou le roi de la balance ambages les
ps tous vexés avec un pèse personne ça
m'étonnerait mois à part ça vous
représentants sur le terrain
il en est content doit écouter tout ce
que je peux vous dire c'est qu'ils ont
la foi voyez alors ils font ils font
beaucoup d'ennuis beaucoup d'ennuis à la
concurrence et d'ailleurs c'était pour
mental on va essayer de me flinguer n ya
pas très longtemps au vieux les affaires
ce salon se défont sont défense puis
finalement qu'est ce qu'il en reste
aulas des clous je sais qu est ce que
vous faites sur le plan de la télé alors
sur le plan de la télé j'ai un petit
truc le dimanche matin vers 10h voyez
enfin vous n'êtes pas 10 heures le matin
mon vieux mais c'est ce que vous êtes à
côté c'est pas un créneau ce bon créneau
c'est une émission quotidienne par
exemple juste avant le journal vous
voyez ce que je veux dire je vais vous
donner un tuyau
je pense que bientôt il va y avoir une
place de libre le seul problème il faut
c'est de vous mettre dans la poche le
présentateur actuelle bah oui mais
qu'est ce que voulait que j'en fasse une
fois très encombrant
la seule chose et le danger c'est qu'ils
confondent le réal et le hula hoop
chaque fois là ya pas trop de problème
j'ai des anneaux drigo donc ça peut
aller mais pour ce qui est du créneau
qu'est ce que je vais en faire bah vous
faites une émission capable de plaire à
tout le monde mais t'es peut-être un
petit peu de faits sans plus et puis
vous utilisez la compétence de ses
collaborateurs ils sont super ben ouais
bah écoute et pourquoi pas écouté je
veux voir avec ceux qui sont là
messieurs lessard
tenez pour l'analyste
tous les bureaux
on est bien parti voyons femme qui est
mathieu c'est moi c'est moi eh ben vous
vous occuperez de la chanson ben je sais
pas chanter vous demanderez à mireille
mathieu
qui est christophe
bon vous occuperez la voiture
voyons voir qui est trop pèse c'est moi
ça y est plus qu on dit mic mac
s'occuperait des du tourisme ok et puis
qui est sa fin c'est moi eh ben vous
vous occuperez de l'apéritif avec votre
collègue dano commence à y en a un il y
en a pas non si on n'a pas à prendre est
un berger sa frappe parfaitement jour un
volontaire pour les courses qui vous est
bien voilà vous saint cloud et ben ça va
très bien il faudrait quelqu'un pour la
danse
bon ben ça vous intéresse la danse c'est
bien ça marche moi je suis saint guy
et vous avez-vous très bien quoi je
parle
quant à moi je fais quoi là et vous
appelez le mans saint-etienne
gérer une affaire l'aventuré et ben
écoutez vous occuperez du sport
apparemment ça a l'air de bien il a les
bons tout le monde est content
apparemment
ça va mieux ça
corps afin de négocier
moi je suis syndicats
[Musique]